bonsoir thomas on parle de la possible
mise en place d'une troisième dose dans
les mois à venir c'est bien ça oui tout
à fait cette réunion se tient parce que
justement pfizer a demandé
l'autorisation auprès des autorités
sanitaires américaines de pouvoir mettre
en place cette fameuse troisième dose il
s'appuie sur une étude de pfizer qui
affirme que cette troisième dose permet
d'augmenter de 5 à 10 fois le nombre
d'anticorps auprès des personnes ayant
déjà reçu deux injections ils appellent
cela un booster shot un booster
d'immunité qui permettrait de lutter
également plus efficacement contre les
variants et qui serait selon pfizer
nécessaires dans les 12 prochains mois
pour les personnes vaccinées alors il ya
un certain nombre de critiques quand
même parce que beaucoup estiment que ce
n'est pas à une entreprise privée et
encore moins un laboratoire
pharmaceutique et d'imposer en quelque
sorte le calendrier de cette campagne de
vaccination aux états unis du côté des
autorités américaines pour l'instant
c'est une piste qui n'est pas
complètement écartée mais elle ne s'est
pas prononcé non plus en faveur de cette
troisième dose écouté par exemple le dr
le docteur anthony fauci à l'heure
actuelle étant donné les résultats les
informations que nous avons nous n'avons
pas besoin d'administrer une troisième
dose cela ne veut pas dire qu'on
s'arrête là il ya des études qui sont
menées en ce moment au sujet de la
faisabilité pour voir si et quand nous
devrions booster la population alors la
porte parole de la maison blanche a
également été interrogé ce lundi sur
cette possible troisième dose elle se
range derrière l'avis des scientifiques
et donc notamment du docteur anthony la
faute chi il faut aussi noter que l'om
slc plutôt prononcé contre cette
troisième dose en expliquant qu'il
fallait d'abord à vacciner largement la
population mondiale avant justement de
mettre en place cette troisième dose
alors du côté du gouvernement américain
la priorité de toute façon pour
l'instant c'est d'abord de vacciner le
plus possible la population la
population américaine vacciner
aujourd'hui à hauteur de 48% 48% des
américains conquis sont complètement
vaccinés dans le pays c'est insuffisant
pour les autorités sanitaires
américaines alors c'est pour cette
raison que joe biden a annoncé la
semaine dernière un certain nombre
deux mesures avec notamment une campagne
de porte porte à porte qui va être
lancée notamment dans les états où la
vaccination est inférieur à ce qu'on
peut connaître par exemple dans les
grandes villes on sait que dans certains
états du sud des états unis
le nombre de personnes vaccinées est
inférieur à la moitié de la population
c'est donc pour cette raison qu'il va y
avoir une campagne de porte à porte qui
va être lancée très prochainement
merci thomas bonnin en direct de
washington